We're kicking it off with
the latest trend in fashion.
Cosmopolitan reports that tennis outfits
are everywhere, on or off the court.
Tennis skirts and polos are the latest look for Spring.
Ross, could you get into this look?
Well, not the skirt.
I don't think I could pull it off, but I love this look.
And even in Palm Springs,
shorter shorts for men, too, are all the rage.
And I think it's cute.
I can get behind it.
I grew up in the era of dolphin shorts,
AKA picture Richard Simmons,
cause he pretty much cornered the market on them.
Now, describe a dolphin short, it's a short...
They're basically...
Yes.
It's shocking any man can
keep their package in them.
(laughs)
Is what you need to know.
They're this short and then they have
a little cutout here,
so they sort of flap.
Yeah.
The first time I saw one was
in a pair of dolphin shorts.
Really?
Oh yeah.
(inaudible)
Flipper escape!
I was like,
Oh, that's what they look like.
I think it's sort of taking this
athleisure thing that we've really embraced
during the pandemic,
and taking it to the next level.
You're right.
Where does athleisure go from here?
And I think the whole tennis thing is super cute.
Nevermind, I can pull off the skirt.
All right.
Hey, question.
Have you ever stayed up late watching Netflix
or reading news on your phone
when you know very well you should be sleeping
like a lamb.
Well, there is a name for that.
And it's called revenge bedtime procrastinating.
And Huff Post reports,
We do it when our days are so busy that
we're fighting for some leisure time at night.
It is an act of revenge to get more time for yourself.
But the byproduct of this cycle is that
we're all wormed over piles of mud the next morning.
Cause we've just stayed up when we should be sleeping.
And I know you've done it, too.
Where you are just like,
This is my time.
I'm going to read the stories I want.
I'm going to play the game I want.
Check the Instagram I want.
Do you do it?
I am so guilty of this
that I was actually shocked
we haven't had this conversation sooner.
That it's only now getting a name because
this is something we do.
And if you're a parent also,
when your kids finally go to sleep you're like,
Oh I need to live an entire lifetime.
And then you're exhausted the next day.
Lather, rinse, repeat.
But don't you think that there's something
healthy about it too?
Sure.
You shouldn't do it every night so you're exhausted,
but I think it is important to
carve out a little time
to do the frivolous stuff that just
feeds your mind and your soul.
Check that Instagram you love.
Do the thing.
I think there's value in it.
Do you mind telling me that tomorrow morning
when I show up at work haggard
from my night of scrolling?
I'll be like,
Oh, it looks like you had some you time last night.
It's so true though.
And you're right.
I'm going to have your inner dialogue
in my head rather than mine.
Yours is much nicer.
Just do a little balance,
just enough.
All right.
Ross, do you remember what you ate
on your first date with Wellington?
Yeah,
we were in Mexico and so we went to get tacos.
We met in the pool,
and then had lunch and got tacos.
Aw, that's so romantic.
Makes me hungry too.
I know.
Interesting. Okay.
Well, let's analyze that data.
so Best Life reports
a new survey claims that
what you ate on your first date
could be a predictor
of the likelihood of your divorce.
What? What did they say about tacos?
Oh, you're good.
Okay.
They surveyed 5,364 people who had been married
and hilariously say if you had Indian food for dinner,
you're doomed.
Excuse me?
And first daters who dined on samosas and naans
had a 67% chance of divorce.
You know what that is?
That's a non-issue.
(they laugh)
A non starter.
First daters who went
with some steak and potatoes,
American fare if you will,
had a 59% divorce rate.
Well, they had a beef with each other.
(they laugh)
Totes.
And those who went for Chinese food
were at a 55% divorce rate.
I mean, what?
This is just coincidence.
Don't you think?
There's nothing to this.
Well, Indian and Chinese are
two of my favorite foods
and I've been divorced three times.
(they laugh)
So I don't know.
Just hearing this and being superstitious,
will you go on a first date and get naan?
Well I'd never have to get married again,
so sure.
Understood.
Thank you so much.
Good answer.
It's NAAN-sense.
(they laugh uproariously)
Oh, come on. (applause)
I had to make you proud.
That was great.
(upbeat music)